NEXT NOVEMBER.
AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
HERE TO RESPOND, CHAIRMAN OF THE
AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE UNION MY
FELLOW OF THE AMERICAN PRINCIPAL
PROJECT, RAYMOND ARROYO,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
RAYMOND, THE 2020 BAND, TRYIN TO
BACK AWAY FRO THE FREEDOM
STATEMENTS MADE, IS THE
STRIKINGLY REALLY CREDIBLE?
>> AM NOT SURE IT IS, LAURA,
BECAUSE EVERY ONE OF THEM
SUPPORTS A QUALITY ACT.
SPEAKER PELOSI PROPOSES LAST
MARCH, ESSENTIALLY, WOULD GIVE A
LOOPHOLE MORE PROTECTION THAN
THE LITTLE SISTERS, LET ME
QUALIFY THAT.
THIS IS AN ANTIDISCRIMINATION
THAT EXALTS A IDENTITY, GENDER
PREFERENCE, ABOUT JUST ABOUT
ANYTHING ELSE.
IT'S A REAL-WORLD IMPLICATIONS,
HOSPITALS THAT REFUSE TO PERFORM
CERTAIN GENDER REASSIGNMENT
SURGERIES AND THEY COULD BE SHUT
DOWN.
RELIGIOUS GROUNDS, THERE ARE NO
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTIONS UNDER THE
EQUALITY ACT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT ORPHANAGES,
ABOUT KIDS WHO THINK THEY'RE
TRANSGENDER, THE PARENTAL RIGHTS
COULD BE TAKEN AWAY FROM PARENTS
IF THEY DENY THESE KIDS CERTAIN
HORMONAL TREATMENTS OR SURGICAL
TREATMENTS.
AS I MENTIONED, THE LITTLE
SISTERS OF BEFORE, THEY'VE BEEN
BATTLING THE OBAMACARE.
IF NOT LEGISLATION, JUST THE
RULE THAT FORCE THEM TO DENIED
THEIR OWN CONTRACT AND PAY FOR
CONTRACEPTION'S.
IF THEY'RE STILL BATTLING THAT'S
IN COURT AND OBAMA SIGNED IT.
>> Laura: THIS IS -- I WANT
EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND TONIGHT,
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT ETHIC A LOT
OF PEOPLE AREN'T COVERING THIS,
THIS IS ACTUALLY WHERE THERE'S A
REAL SKIN IN THE GAME.
THIS IS NOT HYPERBOLE.
THIS SOUNDS GOOD TO CALL
SOMETHING EQUALITY ACT, BUT LIKE
SO MANY OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION, THE EUPHEMISTIC
LANGUAGE DOESN'T CAPTURE WHAT'S
IN THE DETAILS.
>> WHAT REALLY WAS WAS
EMPOWERMENT TO THE TRIAL TO GO
AFTER THE CATHOLIC CHURCH AND
THE CHRISTIAN CHURCHES AND SHUT
THEM DOWN.
HERE WE ARE TODAY, WHERE TO THE
POINT WHERE BETO SAYS YOU CAN'T
REALLY BE A CHURCH IF YOU GIVE
US TERMINATE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST BELIEVERS
AND PEOPLE OF FAITH IN THE
COUNTRY, THE TAKE AWAY
CONSUMPTION TO THE CHURCH AND
YOU NOT GOING TO ALLOW
INSTITUTIONS LIKE THE UNIVERSITY
OF NOTRE DAME TO RECEIVE ANY
KIND OF FEDERAL BENEFITS FOR
STUDENTS.
IF THAT'S ABSOLUTE
DISCRIMINATION.
LET ME TELL YOU, I SEE THIS NEXT
CAMPAIGN, IT'S NOT ABOUT
SOCIALISM, IT'S ABOUT SECULARISM
AND THERE'S A COMBINATION OF THE
TWO.
SOCIALISTS IT'S ABOUT THE
ECONOMICS, THEY DON'T RESPECT
YOUR RIGHT TO
HAVE YOUR OWN BELIEFS AND TO
MAKE YOUR OWN DECISIONS.
>> Laura: FOR THEM, THEY THINK
YOUR BELIEFS, IT'S JUDEO, IT'S
CHRISTIAN, IT'S MUSLIM.
HE WAS VERY EXPLICIT THAT, AND
THE BETO AS AN OUTLIER, HE'S ON
AN OUTLIER.
AOC IS AS CLOSE TO BEING A
THOUGHT LEADER IS THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY AS THERE IS TODAY.
>> THIS ISN'T ABOUT THE THE
PROMOTION OF SECULARISM, BUT TO
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THIS, THIS
IS CANCELING CHRISTIANITY.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
IT'S CANCELING TRADITIONAL
VALUES EVEN AMONGST JIM DOE MY
JEWISH FAMILIES, CHRISTIAN
FAMILIES
THIS GOES BACK INTERESTINGLY
ABOUT 2005 AND LAY CONSIDERATIO
CONSIDERATION.
THEY ALSO RESPONDED TO A
CONFERENCE AT YALE, IT WAS
CALLED THE REHAB       REHABILIT
CALLED THE REHAB       REHABILIH
CALLED THE REHAB       REHABILIE
CONSTITUTION AND BY 2020 IT WAS
CALLED CONSTITUTION 2020, THEY
COULD RANGE THE WHOLE THING,
REMOVING THE UNDERGIRDING OF
WHAT AMERICA IS.
WHEN YOU THING ABOUT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED SINCE I CONFERENCE AND
WHAT THE PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE
AND THEY WERE IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, WERE NOT COMING
AFTER YOUR GUNS.
THE LIBRARY TO LOOK AT THIS NOW,
GAY MARRIAGE WILL BE THE END OF
IT AND WERE NOT GOING TO GO ANY
FURTHER.
LOUD.
LA.
>> Laura: OBAMA SAID HE WAS
AGAINST GAY MARRIAGE.
IT WAS A LIE.
>> DO YOU TRUST THE PEOPLE WHO
IS CONSISTENTLY NOW LIE TO YOU
TIME AND TIME AGAIN ABOUT
INCURSIONS INTO YOUR PRIVATE
LIFE INTO YOUR CHILDREN'S LIVES
AND INTO THE FACT AS RAYMOND WAS
SAYING EARLIER, AN ACT THAT
YOU WILL HAVE YOUNG MEN RUNNING
AGAINST RUNNING TRACK AGAINST
YOUNG GIRLS IN SCHOOL.
>> Laura: HAPPENING ALL OVER
HIGH SCHOOL IN CONNECTICUT, HUGE
HUGE ISSUE.
IF SO, AGAIN, PEOPLE WANT TO SAY
WE DON'T LIKE THIS TWEET OR THAT
SWEET OR TRUMPS TONE.
AT ONE POINT IT'S A CHOICE
BETWEEN RELIGIOUS LIBERTY, FREE
EXPRESSION, THE FIRST AMENDMENT,
THE ENTIRE BILL OF RIGHTS.
WERE GOING TO GET INTO THE NEXT
SEGMENT, THEY WANT TO HOLD A
TRIBUNAL TO PICK A PRESIDENT OUT
OF OFFICE AND SECRETS.
>> IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
POLITICAL SENSE.
THE DEMOCRATS, THIS DIDN'T GET
COVERED IN AUGUST, THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
TO, THEY VOTED ON A PROCLAMATION
TO EXALT AND VENERATE THOSE WITH
NO RELIGIOUS AFFILIATION.
TECHNICALLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
EGGNOG
AGNOSTIC OR ATHEIST, OR IN
TRUMPS CAP A TRY WIN THE PEOPLE
OVER.
AND IT'S A WALL THAT PUSHES
RELIGIOUS PEOPLE AND RELIGIOUS
ESPECIALLY FOR THEIR OUTSIDE
WITH A CONSIDER THE MAINSTREAM.
IF THIS IS SUICIDE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY WOULD DO
THIS.
BUT SUPPORTING THE EQUALITY ACT,
I DON'T SEE HOW IT ENDS WELL
POLITICALLY FOR THEM.
IN THE NATIONAL RACE.
>> Laura: MEANS THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS TO MAKE THIS A
ISSUE, THIS IS WOMEN, BOMBS --
IT'S PEOPLE ACROSS THE BOARD.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO RAISE
THEIR CARES BUT THEY ARE TOLD
THAT THERE ARE EVIL AND
DISCRIMINATORY AND THEIR
TERRIBLE PEOPLE AND ALL OTHER
THINGS THAT THEY ARE TOLD.
AND PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THAT,
LEAVE ME ALONE, DON'T CRAM DOWN
YOUR VALUES TO ME.
BY THE WAY, CORY BOOKER SAID HE
WOULD USE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO TARGET SCHOOLS THAT RESIST
THIS AGENDA.
WATCH.
>> TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO USE THE
BATHROOMS BUT WE CANNOT STOP
THERE.
WE MUST USE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND CIVIL RIGHTS
DIVISION TO GO AFTER SCHOOLS
THAT ARE DENYING PEOPLE EQUAL
RIGHTS AND EQUAL PROTECTION.
>> Laura: MATS, MORE PEOPLE
ARE SEEING THE TOWN HALL ON THE
SHOW BUT ITS IMPORTANCE,
WERE PLAYING IT FOR A REASON.
MOST PEOPLE THAT WATCH LIST,
THIS IS WHERE THE PARTY IS
GOING.
YOU   USING GOVERNMENT AS A WEAP
YOU   USING GOVERNMENT AS A WEAN
AGAINST PEOPLE.
>> IT STARTED WITH OBAMA, SPYING
ON REPORTERS, SING FCC
LAWYERS INTO NEWSROOMS.
IT WAS THE D.C. GOVERNMENT
ASKING FOR THE SERMONS AND
PASTORS SEEING IF THERE IS HATE
SPEECH AND KNOW YOU HAVE
CORY BOOKER WHO IS LITERALLY
RUNNING TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND HE'S GOING TO
USE THE DOJ TO AGAINST THEM CAN
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE SAME BELIEFS
THAT GEORGE WASHINGTON HAD AND
OUR FOUNDERS.
>> Laura: OBAMA -- I MEAN,
OBAMA WOULD BE CONSIDERED WHAT
TODAY?
IN THIS DEMOCRAT PARTY, WHEN HE
CAMPAIGNED AND WHEN HE SAID.
RED STATE AMERICA, BLUE STATE,
NO, NO, NO, THEY WANT TO JUST BE
BLUE STATE AMERICA.
RED STATE AMERICA, IF YOU DO   D
RED STATE AMERICA, IF YOU DO   E
RED STATE AMERICA, IF YOU DO   O
RED STATE AMERICA, IF YOU DO   F
OPIATE ADDICTION, THAT'S TOO BAD
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT YOU.
>> YET GRETA THUNBERG APPROVED P
>> YET GRETA THUNBERG APPROVED R
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF O
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF T
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF K
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF E
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF O
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF T
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF B
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF S
STRAW PEA SHOOTER AND STEAD OF .
>> Laura: THERE IS DISHONEST
MOMENTS IN THE MEDIA, THIS IS
ONE OF THEM, ELIZABETH WARREN
HAD A VIRAL MOMENTS AT LAST
WEEK'S TOWN HALL AFTER AN
AUDIENCE MEMBER ASKED THIS
QUESTION.
>> THE SUPPORTER APPROACHES YOU
AND SAID MY SENATOR, I'M
OLD-FASHIONED AND THEY TEACHES
ME THAT MARRIAGE IS BETWEEN ONE
MAN AND ONE WOMAN, WHAT'S YOUR
RESPONSE?
>> I'M GOING TO ASSUME IT'S A
GUY THAT SAID THAT, AND I'M
GOING TO SAY, JUST MARRY ONE
MOMENT.
ASSUMING YOU CAN FIND ONE.
>> Laura: I MEAN, RAYMOND,
TURNS THE QUESTION ARE OF
COURSE, HE KNEW IT WAS
CHOREOGRAPHED, IT WAS SO
OBVIOUSLY PLANNED.
SOMEONE NAMED MORGAN ACTUALLY IS
A BAG DON'T LIKE BIG WARREN
DONOR.
HE'S REACHED THE LEGAL MAX TWICE
FOR THE CAMPAIGN OF WARREN AND
HER PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THEY PULLED OUT THE LITTLE
SCHEME AND CNN, THEY KNOW ABOUT
IT AND THE REFINED ABOUT THIS,
AND TUCKER WAS AT PLOTTING ADS,
WHATEVER.
IT WAS >> IT WAS A HUGE
RESPONSE, BUT LET ME LAY IT OUTT
RESPONSE, BUT LET ME LAY IT OUTE
RESPONSE, BUT LET ME LAY IT OUTY
THINK.
THERE'S A RICH RELIGIOUS TO
SOCIAL NETWORK IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEY SERVE THE HOMELESS, THEY
PAY EDUCATIONAL LEADER, AND
HOSPITALS, WE ARE RISKING
SHEDDING ALL OF THOSE DOWN.
ORPHANAGES HAVE ALREADY GONE OUT
OF BUSINESS, HOSPITALS ARE
ENDANGERED, I JUST READ THE
CASE, A MAN IDENTIFYING AS A
WOMAN WANTED ACCESS TO A WOMAN'S
HOMELESS SHELTER THEY TURN HIM
DOWN.
HE CONTINUALLY SUING HIM TRYING
TO GET ACCESS TO THE PLACE.
WHAT YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
EVENTUALLY DO, EITHER SHUT DOWN
OR GIVE UP BECAUSE OF THE
LITIGATION?
THIS IS WHAT THE QUALITY ACT
ENDS THIS PATIENT BEING CUT FOR
IT COULD LEAD US TO.
IT'S A BAD END.
A BETTER AMERICA COME ABOUT FOR
THOSE LOOKING AND NEEDING HELP
ON THE STREETS TO NINE.
>> Laura: ACROSS THE BOARD,
THIS CONVERSATION IS CRITICAL
FOR THE ELECTION NEXT YEAR.
THESE ARE THE ISSUES THAT MUST
NOT BE STARTED.